hey everyone the Sears register nurse re
and calm and in this video I'm going to
go over how to read syringes in this
video I want to go over five basic
syringes that you will be using as a
nurse and show you how to read each of
them now as a nurse you're going to have
a lot of different types of syringes at
your disposal and you want to select the
correct syringe for the amount of
medication that you want to get for
instance say that the physician has
ordered 0.5 milliliters of morphine the
3 cc syringe is the best for drawing
that medication up to get the most
accurate dose however on the other hand
if you're going to give point 2 5
milliliters of a medication the 1
milliliter syringe is the best for that
so let me show you the basic parts of a
syringe here is a basic 10 milliliter
syringe and anytime you have a syringe
you always want to look at its total
capacity it can hold and this one holds
10 MLS now as a side note 10 MLS is the
same as 10 cc's so if you hear someone
say let's give 2 cc's it's the same as
two MLS just to let you know that now
let's go over the basic parts of the
syringe okay so here at the top this is
our adapter part and this is where you
would screw on the needle if you were
going to give an iamb injection and now
in the hospital we use needle list
devices so we would just screw this
adapter part on to the IV the hub of the
IV or the line and then we would just
give our medication that way now the
other part that's important is the
barrel of the syringe the barrel has a
scale on it and this scale tells us how
much of a medication we're gonna give
based on whatever the doctor ordered now
every syringe is different and how it
measures that's why I say get familiar
with how much your syringe holds which
we're going to go over in depth here in
a second with each individual syringe
and you have a scale so at the top it's
zero then you have a line in between
that and then you have one then you
and then you have a big - and it
measures onward now one thing that you
want to keep in mind is how to actually
measure the fluid that you're drawing up
with this plunger so let's go over the
other part the plunger I'm going to take
it out so you can see it the plunger has
a top part and a bottom part and it also
has a beveled area and whenever you're
actually drawing up the medication
you're going to line the line up that's
on the scale of your barrel with this
top part of the plunger not the beveled
part the top part now let's go over how
to read each syringe first we're going
to start with the easiest syringe which
is the 10 milliliter or 10 cc syringe
and as you can tell on this picture each
area is measured out so the top part
where the top line is 0.5 milliliters
then it goes to one then the next line
is 1.5 then it goes to two then the next
line is 2.5 and so on so this syringe
based on how its scale is set up in its
capacity it measures by 0.5 now let's
test your knowledge based on the yellow
wine what is the measurement of this
syringe and the answer is 4.5 MLS now
let's look at the five milliliter
syringe and as you can see on this this
has a little bit more lines in between
the main measurements than the 10 cc
syringe and that very top line is zero
and then below zero you have 0.2 then
point four seven point six point eight
and then the huge line is one so that is
where one milliliter is at then after
that you'll count by twos the point twos
so to be 1.2 1.4 1.6 1.8 and 2 and then
so on it would keep measuring that a
male until you hit 5 MLS now let's look
at this syringe based on the yellow wine
what is the measurement of this syringe
the answer is 2.2 MLS now let's look at
our 3 no
leader syringe this syringe even further
breaks down the measurement so you can
really draw up a smaller amount of a
medication for instance like I said at
the beginning of the video this syringe
is really good for drawing up a
medication if you just have to give
point five of something so that top line
is zero then as you pull the plunger
down this syringe goes down by point one
so you have 0.1 ml 0.2 0.3 0.4 and then
you have half 0.5 then you have point
six point seven point eight point nine
and then one and then so on until you
get a total capacity of three MLS based
on the yellow wine what is the
measurement of this syringe
the answer is 0.7 MLS our next syringe
is the one milliliter syringe and this
syringe if you don't have good eyesight
you really have to squint to see the
little lines but it's really good for
giving those medications where you have
to give just a little bit like the 0.25
MLS
okay on this syringe as you can see and
the top line will be zero and then this
particular syringe will measure down by
0.01 so you have point zero one point
zero two point zero three onward until
you hit point one ml's and then it'll
just keep on going until you've hit a
total capacity of 1 in MLS
based on the yellow wine what is the
measurement of this syringe
the answer is 0.25 MLS okay this is our
very last syringe and this is a syringe
that you will be using a lot whenever
you are giving diabetics insulin and it
is a syringe that holds a total of a
hundred units because insulin is
measured in units and it looks a little
similar to our one milliliter syringe
that we went over but it's not measured
in milliliters it's measured in units so
as you can see with this we have our top
line which is zero and this is going to
measure in increments of two so the next
line would be two units
then four units six units eight units
and then ten units and then onward until
you would give a total of a hundred
units based on the yellow wine what is
the measurement of this syringe
the answer is 72 units okay so that
wraps up this video on how to read the
common syringes you will encounter as a
nurse thank you so much for watching and
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for more videos